non
j'en passe
la vie
vous êtes très nombreux et nombreuses à
m'avoir demandé de traiter un sujet en
particulier c'est celui du conflit entre
israël et la palestine est en fait vous
avez complètement raison parce que c'est
un sujet qui est super important et dont
on ne parle plus beaucoup alors que les
tensions sont toujours aussi vives sur
place alors j'ai sauté dans un avion
pour me rendre à jérusalem qui est
vraiment la ville symbole de ce conflit
jérusalem c'est une ville qu à plus de
5000 ans d'histoire et c'est aussi la
ville sainte des trois religions du
livre donc le judaïsme le christianisme
et 10 femmes alors cette ville elle est
coupée en deux depuis les années 40
alors pour faire très très simple un vin
côté à l'ouest et les israéliens juifs
et de l'autre à l'est des palestiniens
musulmans en réalité c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça et c'est bien ça le
problème
les palestiniens comme pour les
israéliens jérusalem c'est leur capital
et c'est de là que viennent une grande
partie des tensions
depuis plus de 50 ans en fait des
israéliens il grignote de plus en plus
de territoire à jérusalem est donc et
territoires palestiniens ça continue
encore aujourd'hui et dans la plupart
des cas en fait les maisons des
palestiniens sont rachetés par des
organisations juives et les autorités
israéliennes ensuite expulsé de force
les familles palestiniennes qui y vivent
pour des familles juives viennent s'y
installer et l'onu considère que
jérusalem est est un territoire occupé
illégalement
la communauté internationale à
nombreuses fois condamné l'état d'israël
mais en réalité ça change pas grand
chose alors je suis allé à jérusalem en
plein mois du ramadan c'est un mois où
il ya généralement beaucoup de tensions
entre les communautés juive et musulmane
pour comprendre un petit peu comment ça
se passait sur place
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
thiam a fait le
en même temps moubarak ahmed abed hamoud
d'immenses casquette beige
faustine inamori 10ème firefox ou élite
alors fico l'échec la maladie ont
alerté leurs maubeuge à l'automne chez
béjart ici haman adama dolo jette les
stars sofia où le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
m
non
comité des plusieurs fois je peux le
voir des réalisations qui sont hyper
calme mais
quand même envolée part de leur devise
leur mode de bolliger
balade des choses quelqu'un en plo
hazard qui
par qui je fouille
et ensuite il
hiver au bout de quelques minutes
pour entretenir la peur aussi parmi les
jeunes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
deux formations
sur les réseaux sociaux et des vidéos
qui sont hyper populaires qui font des
centaines de milliers voire des millions
de vues par x ou y et des jeunes
palestiniens qui provoque les israéliens
et la police
vidéo
lors du ramadan mahé dernière il ya
cette vidéo tik tok d'un adolescent
palestinien qui gifle un jeune israélien
religion tramway à jérusalem
qui avait mené à une escalade de
violence complètement dingue
[Musique]
en fait cette vidéo de la gifle elle va
être utilisée comme argument par des
groupes radicaux juifs pour appeler à se
venger ensuite sonné palestiniens
et sur les réseaux ces vidéos de
représailles elles sont partout en
israël comme en palestine en fait tout
le monde fim tout le temps soit pour
accuser soit pour provoquer l'autre camp
obama
[Applaudissements]
ce partenariat version comme éric
veilleux la nôtre je me retire le cheveu
adams et ibrahim shekarau valero c'est
comme écrire notre bel rtl à la vente et
à limoger deux hommes sont avec les
shebab et manger des nôtres
là
momo
[Applaudissements]
à
m
six mois d'août
la taille
de
la flotte ce jour là
[Musique]
le
alors là je me trouve dans le quartier
de silwan un coeur des quartiers
résidentiels de jérusalem est qui est
considéré comme un territoire occupé et
en fait ici se déroule une véritable
guerre de territoires en fait ya plus
d'une centaine de familles
palestiniennes qui vivent ici depuis des
générations qui sont menacés d'expulsion
pour être remplacés par des familles de
colons juifs ces expulsions ils sont
considérés totalement illégales par la
communauté internationale mais les
familles juives qui sont soit des
familles ultra orthodoxes elle considère
que ces talents appartiennent et que
jérusalem est la capitale d'israël
[Musique]
des six mois ils doivent s'élever
de cellules
et dames this is my fathers
investissements et
my family now
so et my father my family now and roll
all wheel et des machines gordon aux
deux mollets dernier des trois femmes il
y avait des femmes il est le produit
d'un animateur les stocks totaux
et des expulsions de familles
palestiniennes quasiment tous les mois
et ces expulsions en fait elles sont
appuyées par des décisions de justice
israélienne alors il ya beaucoup de loin
qui sont utilisés dans ces cas-là mais a
surtout une loi qui en fait permet un
juif de réclamer la propriété d'un
terrain dont ses ancêtres ont été
expulsés dans la création de l'état
d'israël donc à l'époque où la ville de
jérusalem a été coupée en deux mais en
fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
cette loi elle ne s'applique qu'aux
juifs et pas aux arabes qui eux en fait
ne peuvent pas réclamer les terres de
leurs aînés ont été expulsés eux aussi à
ce moment là en 1948
[Musique]
véronic
dicaire
flegme
[Musique]
août
2009 avec interview
nous
dénonçons
des
cépages je conviens
de
5,3
l'office est vidée au président
et aux frères losing
et families
aujourd'hui le béa flop
comme invité
j'ai essayé d'interviewer certains de
ces israélienne et ces israéliens qui
vivent dans ce quartier pour avoir un
petit peu leur vision des choses en fait
ils étaient tous hyper réticent à parler
devant ma caméra alors j'ai tenté du
coup ma chance avec une caméra plus
discrète plus petit qui impressionne
moins les gens et après beaucoup de
refus ya finalement un habitant qui a
accepté de me parler à l'homme femdh
journalistes
l'accueil
de
jour
les propos d'antoine
thank you
et au final j'ai réussi à avoir rendez
vous avec daniel luria alors c'est un
homme qui est très médiatique qui en
fait le porte parole d'une association
de colons israéliens et qui milite 1
pour l'installation de familles juives à
jérusalem est faisant donc dans les
quartiers qui sont considérés par la
communauté internationale comme occupés
à main ahmadou
famille
qui pour la cuistrerie bingham
l'extérieur chose we need
and stories
alors derrière moi en fait vous pouvez
voir d'immenses murs 1 qui sépare israël
de la palestine là je suis du côté
palestinien et ça c'est l'un des
nombreux checkpoints qui permet de
passer à jérusalem est comme on est
vendredi aujourd'hui en fait y'a plein
de palestiniens qui veulent se rendre à
la mosquée el aqsa pour aller prier
alors cette année les autorités
israéliennes ont fait une règle un petit
peu spéciale en fait tous les hommes de
plus de 50 ans et les femmes de plus de
45 ans normalement
le droit de passer ses objectifs sans
autorisation spéciale en réalité c'est
un petit peu plus compliqué que ça parce
que hier soir hier un attentat
terroriste à tel-aviv qui a fait deux
morts donc ça a vraiment tendu la
situation
[Musique]
à dubaï à 3,2 m
rester chez lui
[Musique]
donc là je me trouve devant une des onze
porte un qui mêle à la mosquée el aqsa
donc la mosquée al aqsa c'est quand même
un des trois lieux saints dans l'islam
donc en fait le ramadan il ya parfois
certains jours près de 6000 personnes
qui viennent prier ici à des policiers
israéliens devant chaque porte qui
contrôle un peu les entrées et les
sorties
donc là justement on peut voir en fait
il ya pas mal de tensions et de grands
chantres des gens
qui viennent se faire arrêter je sais
pas exactement pourquoi par la police et
l'israélienne
cas les policiers israéliens qui me
demande d'arrêter de filmer
juste avant que cet homme s'est pas
arrêté je t'en rends debout dit
justement qui à des policiers israéliens
devant chacune des portes qui mènent à
la mosquée et y est même un commissariat
à l'intérieur avec parfois des
patrouilles de police israélienne
pendant les prières et ça ça crée
énormément de tension
[Musique]
à quand on se balade dans la ville de
jérusalem il ya un truc qui est vraiment
très frappant ses convois défense de
leurs israélienne vraiment à tous les
coins de rue en fait ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est quelle et trois attentats
juste avant le mois du ramadan et du
coup le gouvernement israélien a annoncé
qu'ils déploient et plus de 3000
policiers dans la ville donc vraiment
landreau sort énormément
[Musique]
bien on voit qu'ils ont été érigés dans
la mosquée parce que c'est la prière
principale du vendredi donc est quand
même pas mal de gens un conte réussi à
terrasser les tchèques funk ya vraiment
des gens de toute la palestine qui sont
vieux et prier on va les suivre un petit
peu borat
à l'arrivée
[Musique]
amy aux comités formés au lean est
pourtant un tracteur
m
la mosquée el aqsa elle au centre de
toutes les tensions à jérusalem en fait
qu'être très régulièrement des
affrontements sur l'esplanade et l'année
dernière les affrontements ils ont mené
à une baisse de 11 jours entre israël et
gaza et cette année les incidents
recommence la raison de cette tension
c'est que pour les musulmans c'est un
des lieux les plus sacrés de l'islam
mais pour les juifs aussi car en fait
ils appellent l' endroit le mont du
temple en souvenir à un temple juif
détruit l époque romaine qui était
exactement sur ce lieu
[Musique]
le conflit israélo palestinien il dure
depuis plus de 70 ans et franchement
c'est impossible de tout vous raconter
dans une seule vidéo tant le sujet est
ultra complexe si certains ou certaines
d'entre vous veulent creuser un peu plus
ce sujet en profondeur je vous mets des
liens en descriptions pour aller plus
loin j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu et
que vous avez appris des choses c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
partager et à commenter et je vous dis à
très bientôt
[Musique]